[Music]
is Buffy Summers here tonight she is
desperate to go to the prom and have her
one normal high school experience angel
breaks up with puffy and she's
heartbroken and it's a whole dilemma as
happens to a lot of people who struggle
to prom for myself and enjoy it or why
can't I have that one normal high school
moment if this really happened be she's
done her slave and she's not gonna come
with ever the whole idea is a basic
machine yes we're gonna have a good time
whatever yeah
there's no gonna ruin our problem I'm
gonna give you all a nice fun normal
evening if I have to kill every single
person on the face of the earth to do it
yay I have a date yeah um and she acted
the problem men are evil you go with me
so I'm going um and it's pretty much
just jeans and ER and love hell what is
the story of change life more
importantly I have the kick dress well
we we looked at Pamela genesis liquor
and we came across three that were our
favorite and then the executive producer
and Pamela Candice everyone agreed that
this was the one and they even had the
matching clip in my hair nice to send
them out to the brush and everyone looks
so Ally she's so beautiful not a
handsome
hi you stepped on my train Lada stepping
on my train right he does that
constantly yeah but I used to be she's
got a long train accident waiting to
happen
[Music]
you